My name is Vaati.
And welcome to Dark Souls 2.
So I'm not the kind of person
or not the kind of channel
to do things in half-measures.
My videos require a lot of editing
and let's plays rarely require much.
So in this series I'm going to make it different.
I'm gonna keep it fast-paced.
Maybe even introduce a new theme
to every episode, you know...
The theme of this episode is:
how to get the best possible start.
So I ask you guys,
my subscribers:
to join me in adventuring
through Drangleic.
There's a lot to see and we're going to be discovering this entire game,
one video at a time in 2014.
Things Betwixt
A huge part of this game
is curing the curse of undeath.
Our character travels to
this old decrepit castle,
but upon arriving he realizes that it has another side to it.
And further on in the cinematic
he actually gets drawn into this vortex,
and I say drawn because,
he's not just drawn
by some need to cure the curse.
It seems like he's literally forced
into this hole:
his pupil explodes in Darkness
and his hand starts writhing,
and this just indicates to me
that he's being drawn in there.
Anyway, as you progress through
you come across these dogs.
And you know, this is the reason the start of Dark Souls 2 really appeals to me,
And it's probably
my masochistic side saying this:
but if you wait in this section too long,
these dogs start to surround you,
and if you provoke them, like I've done,
then they'll chase you down,
and make you become a bit more wary of the fact
that you're wearing rags,
and that you have like
no health.
They chase you towards
this warm light...
..and that's where
we're gonna go next.
I actually spy this item off near this tree,
this is something you should pick up,
because we'll find its use later in the tutorial.
In regards to this cinematic:
you can skip it if you like,
but I have overlaid a lot of game-play
so it's more interesting.
"Heh heh heh...
What seems to be the ruckus?
Ooh, my!
Your face.
The face of the curse."
"It's an Undead.
An Undead has come to play.
Heh heh...
They all end up here,
all the ones like you.
You spoke to that kind old dear,
didn't you?
Heh heh...
You're finished.
You'll go Hollow.
Yes, you will become one of them.
Hollows prey upon men...
..feast upon their souls.
This is the fate of the cursed.
Heh heh heh..."
THE OLD LADIES LAUGH
So, we're not the only ones
who were drawn here.
Let's find out a bit more about
where we are:
"This is a limbo.
A link between Drangleic...
..and the outer world.
Fair traveler...
..I know that you must have a story.
Why else would you visit
such a place?
This lost, decayed kingdom.
My name is Milibeth.
The old women were once Fire Keepers.
I am here to look after them.
It is what my mother did,
and her mother before her,
and so on.
But now, the fire shows
signs of fading…
And the kingdom...
..is beset by Hollows.
The old women are sisters.
I am told there was a fourth.
Long ago,
Fire Keepers were commonplace.
But now they are lost,
scattered to the winds."
VAATI:
So after being made fun of for a little while,
by all these old women,
we're gonna head back outside,
into the tutorial area.
If you were watching during that cinematic
then you would have seen me
go through this hole in the bushes,
just before that bridge.
And this guy, this is the reason
we picked a sorcerer:
So we could take out this guy.
As soon as you see
these big enemies,
I'm sure you're all thinking:
"You know if I kill that now,
I bet I get an awesome item!"
And you do get a pretty cool item
from this guy,
he's the only Ogre in this level
that will give you an item.
The item is called:
Stone Ring.
What it does is:
every time you hit an enemy
it decreases their poise,
a lot more than if you
didn't have the ring on.
So basically you'll break their poise more often
when you smash them,
and I think that's really good for weapons
that attack quickly,
although I'm not sure.
So now he's gone,
we're gonna take his item.
Further on is some Gold Pine Resin.
And then we're gonna continue
with the actual tutorial,
which I won't show much of,
because it's not that interesting.
"You must go, on a journey without rest.
Well...I suppose,
if you find yourself at an impasse...
But if your will
is yet unbroken...
..then you may return here.
To start again,
with a clean slate...
Hah hah hah..."
VAATI:
So, the journey begins:
Light this bonfire.
Over to the right is a wagon:
behind the wagon is a torch.
I think I should mention
how the torch mechanic works in this game:
every torch contributes 5 minutes of lit time
towards your counter.
You can light the torch at the bonfire,
by toggling with triangle
or whatever button that is on Xbox.
And you can light your torch.
Right now I'm like, you know,
there's so many torches in this tutorial...
I'm going to light
every single one of them,
I am going to see
if something happens.
As one of our characters
is currently doing that...
..our other character
is going to check out this coffin.
We'll go back to the character
who's lighting torches...
But for now,
let's see what this coffin is:
It's surrounded by these Ogres,
surely if you get in, something happens, right?
I just want you guys,
if you haven't got in the coffin:
try it, and tell me
what you noticed changes.
Something changes.
I'm not going to tell you.
First time I found this coffin,
it was like...
..in previous versions of the game
it actually floated away,
and you're just like:
"Okay, am I going to another area?"
But no, you appear in the same area.
As soon as you get out:
you're attacked
by these two guys immediately.
You don't get a chance to think,
and I think that was intentional.
They know you couldn't kill them,
so they wanted you to run to it, and get in,
and try to figure out
what's changed.
It took me like,
I got halfway through my game,
before I realized
what changed.
And I want to know
if you guys figured it out.
Go trough the tutorial:
you'll find a nest.
And I think you know
what's coming...
Drop the Smooth Silky Stone
we found earlier in the level,
or drop the Petrified Something
that you started with,
and you'll get a reward.
DYNA:
"Yah, yah, so nice, so smooth."
TILLO:
"Yah, yah, silky smooth."
So Snuggly the Crow is back,
and it looks like she has a friend.
Anyway back to our Cleric,
who is currently lighting torches,
you get to the end and:
FLATLY:
nothing happens.
Don't light the torches,
it's a waste of time...
So let's finish this tutorial
with our main character.
Honestly, I didn't need to light a torch
for this little cave section, but...
..you know darkness on YouTube
isn't a great thing...
..and any excuse to use a torch
I just jump at in this game.
I love the way the shadows look,
and the way the lighting looks is just incredible, especially at the start of the game.
So you come out into Majula,
your eyes take a second
to adjust to the harsh light.
And this is the hub area
that you're going to be traveling back to.
There are a bunch of
important NPC's in Majula,
and coming back after a boss
to spend your souls and rest is a huge thing.
LENIGRAST:
"Who are you?
Oh, it doesn't matter,
just help me open this door.
I packed my tools in here,
seeing it was vacant...
..but now somebody's gone
and locked the door."
And that's Lenigrast; the blacksmith who can't fit
through the giant open window(!)
We're going to find the key for his house
a little bit later in the walkthrough.
But for now,
we're going to talk to the woman
who is probably the most important character in Majula.
EMERALD HERALD:
"Are you...the next monarch?
Or...merely a pawn of fate?
Bearer of the curse...
I will remain by your side.
Till this frail hope shatters...
Take this with you.
May it ease your journey.
Go on, and see the King.
He who made Drangleic
what it once was;
he who peered at
the essence of the soul:
King Vendrick.
Bearer of the curse,
seek misery.
For misery will lead you to
greater, stronger souls.
You will never meet the King
with a soul so frail and pallid.
Seek those whose names
are unutterable,
the four endowed
with immense souls.
Their souls will serve
as beacons.
Once you have found them,
return here to me.
So that hope will not fade away."
VAATI:
"So that hope will not fade away."
God, I love that dialogue!
I especially love the bit
where she talks about finding the King.
I really like when games set up the fact that you're going to be this incredible character later on,
you start off small,
but later in the game
you know you're going to take out someone
who is a huge problem,
or someone who is hugely powerful
compared to you.
So now we're going to adventure through
the Forest of the Fallen Giants.
And that name, and this area,
is interesting from a lore perspective.
Long ago, there was a battle,
a war with the Giants.
And whenever a Giant fell in battle:
a tree would grow from its point of death.
And that's essentially
what this entire forest is made of.
So you can get some sort of idea
of the scale of the battle
that must have taken place.
And when I played through this for the first time,
and even now,
I thought:
"God damn, that's great game design"
You come up from the ladder
and you see this vista.
And immediately
there's so much to take in:
There's four enemies wandering around,
that you're going to have to take out.
There's this archer up the top,
shooting at you.
And there's this little crestfallen knight,
sitting at the tree;
You don't know, is he hostile?
Is he going to attack me?
Soon enough you figure out:
no, he's not going to attack you.
In previous versions of the game though,
he used to be very aggressive.
In previous versions of the game:
you actually had to skirt
around the outside of the arena
in case you got too close to him.
Because if you got too close,
he would attack you.
But in this version,
we're going to run up this side passage,
and we're going
to take out the archer.
And then we're going
to fight the Heide Knight.
And the Heide Knight drops
a really, really good straight sword;
its imbued with Lightning,
does a good amount of damage,
has an all right move set.
Personally I like the Longsword
-- that we're going to find in a few minutes --
a little bit better.
So killing him is fairly optional,
but you know,
if you feel like fighting him:
go for it.
He's definitely not
an easy fight,
and we'll go through the fight
a little bit in detail in about a minute.
But right now:
let's take out this archer.
Just take him out...
..I'm good at this game,
I promise.
See...
..oh, I almost fell off,
but I didn't.
I'm so good(!)
So this character isn't
going to kill the Heide Knight.
We're going to actually get a fire Longsword,
later in the level.
So this character is gonna make this jump,
get this item.
And I'll show you
how to kill the Heide Knight.
My hot tips for this guy
revolve around one thing:
learn his moveset!
As soon as he finishes his moves;
attack him once,
you'll have just enough time to roll away,
before his next one connects with you.
He does have a few moves
that will surprise you,
but those are surprises,
and this is Dark Souls!
So I'm not going
to spoil them for you.
What is this?
A walkthrough(?!)
So let's grab his sword
and continue with the walkthrough...
So we continue along up these stairs
and we take out a group of enemies.
A common trend I've found in Dark Souls 2
is to take out melee enemies
while having a ranged enemy
attacking you in some way.
Make sure you be careful of those fire bombs:
they do a fair bit of damage!
So after this we're going to climb this ladder,
we're going to go inside,
and we're going to light a bonfire.
Finally!
One thing to mention about lighting bonfires
this time around is that:
The act of lighting a bonfire,
triggers it as a checkpoint.
Which means you no longer have to rest there,
and respawn enemies,
to trigger it as a checkpoint.
This is Melentia.
She sells a bunch of
great consumable items:
5 Human Effigies, 10 Radiant Lifegems,
Throwing Knives,
which are wonderful this time around.
And most importantly,
the Blacksmith's key,
which you're gonna need.
But once we've got the blacksmith unlocked,
we need something to upgrade!
So we're going to get
what is probably my favorite starting weapon:
The fire Longsword.
And it's in an interesting location.
So once you've
dropped down that ledge,
It's a matter of doing some minor platforming
to make it down to the bottom,
while taking out
these Hollow Soldiers on the way.
Interesting thing about
these Hollow Soldiers:
they were once part of the war
against the Giants,
but they've all Hollowed now.
You can just see that:
they're destined to wander around here aimlessly,
until they see someone's souls to take.
So this is a cave that turns away
a lot of new players.
At this point,
you might have been playing for a while,
or you don't exactly feel
like dying,
and when you see
this cave full of fire, you're like:
"Will that burn me when I go in?"
You go in a bit further, there's this thing shooting fireballs, and you're like:
"I'm not going in there."
But it rewards
the courageous player,
it rewards the person
who's looking to take risks.
Grab this tentatively and run back.
And you might be able to spy
this door to the left:
open it quickly,
in between bursts.
Maybe better than I did,
and you might be lucky enough to roll inside.
This...is the fire Longsword.
And it's probably
my favorite weapon so far.
if you don't feel like using the fire Longsword
for whatever reason,
there are a lot of options
you can actually get from the Blacksmith,
so head back to Majula,
rest, spend your souls.
And then we'll head
deeper into this castle.
We've seen some ambushes
in previous levels,
but it's nothing compared
to what you're gonna see here.
I think one good rule of thumb
for this level is;
if an enemy looks dead:
It's not dead, and it's going to
try and kill you later in the level.
So make sure you get the first hit in,
like I am.
Eventually we're going to make it
to a fog gate.
And this is where you make a choice,
because this is where the path branches.
Over to the right: we see this decrepit housing
further down lower by the wall.
On the wall,
on the ramparts:
we see a bunch of enemies
that are actually quite tricky to take out.
Especially as you get further on,
you'll see what I mean...
To end up that ladder is death,
let's not go there right now right now.
Right now, we're going to see these barrels
at the far end, near a wall.
If you see black barrels near a wall:
I think you know what to do to them...
..I'm gonna show you
what to do to them.
This is what you do to them:
After you've been blown up
by 10 barrels of gunpowder...
..just walk it off, you know.
Go through this hole
in the wall you created,
and you'll realize:
you created a shortcut.
At this point in the game,
if you climb this ladder,
I hope you've spent all your souls,
because you're most likely going to die.
Up this ladder is one of the only
bosses that comes to you,
and he only comes to you once.
So you get one chance to take him out here,
if you don't take him out here:
you can fight him later in the level,
in a designated area.
If you fight him early,
do you get something special for it?
Well, let's see.
This is the Pursuer.
SILENCE
"The Pursuer, who hunts down
the bearer of the sign,
will not rest until his target is slain.
The Pursuer hunts down those branded by the curse,
as if each Undead soul that he claims
will atone one of his sins."
I love the concept of this boss.
That feeling you get when you see
him fly towards you on that eagle,
and realizing I'm halfway through the level,
and I have to fight a boss now?!
then if you have the courage to fight him, you can get your ass kicked,
or you can jump off the ledge
and run away completely,
there are two options open to you.
I decided to take him on,
and needless to say...
..I regretted it.
I regretted it a lot.
But my curiosity had to be satisfied,
so I came back on another character.
I have 30 Soul Arrows,
and I know his moveset.
So I'm gonna try,
and take him on.
The one thing about this boss
that makes him easy:
is that he has
a very limited move set.
And he tells his moves
really obviously.
That stab attack will curse you
if you get too close,
but like I said:
you can see it coming a mile away.
And this is the attack right there,
that's the one you hit him after.
He'll raise his shield
and dash at you:
roll out of the way,
It's your only option.
And then counter attack, once.
You might be able to get two hits in,
but one is safe.
I only had 30 Soul Arrows
and a dagger for this fight,
and luckily;
you just have enough Soul Arrows
to take him out.
Don't waste any
on the way here, use 30.
With a Sorcerer,
you'll be able to take him out.
For killing the Pursuer;
we get a Ring of Blades,
which increases physical damage.
And we get his souls.
If you don't kill him in here,
you have the chance of killing him later.
But do you get anything extra
for killing him early?
No, unfortunately you don't.
Back on our main character,
we decide to go a different way.
This is the route
we traveled up earlier.
And on the right you see
all the decrepit housing.
We're gonna make this jump.
I'm going to take out
some enemies here.
And we're eventually
going to make it to this cave.
Once you get in:
just keep running straight through,
nothing's going to kill you(!)
Up this hill we'll meet Cale,
who's a great example of why talking to NPC's
will give you some great rewards.
He's also one of those few characters
who's nice to you.
Even though his mind has been decayed
by the curse.
CALE:
"Oh, I'm sorry.
I was just…
..daydreaming, I think.
My name is Cale.
I am a traveller,
like yourself.
I'm navigating the continent
to create a map.
Have you seen Majula?
There's a rather spacious mansion there.
I…I've made it my temporary home.
Inside the mansion,
I found a strange map.
Like none I'd ever seen.
I believe that it's
a map of Drangleic.
Now I'm travelling the land to prove it.
Yes, yes, that's it!
That's why I came to the kingdom!
Wait…No, that wasn't it…
Then what? I don't seem to recall…"
In the next episode:
We travel to this crumbling city,
filled with these ancient giants.
This one, the second one you fight,
gave me Sublime Bone Dust,
which you can burn in the Majula bonfire
to make your Estus Flask stronger.
I recommend going here early.
Another great item is available further on,
which stops you from losing so much health
once you're Hollowed.
This is found just before
the Cathedral of Blue,
the drawbridge of which can be lowered,
if you take out the giants.
And once we go up there,
we'll find an old friend waiting inside...
FOG GATE RUSTLES
Click the bonfire to figure out what
"kindling the channel" will do.
This is a campaign I'm going to launch soon,
and it's going to bring some amazing results.
I actually can't wait to read
the comments about Dark Souls 2:
so if you have an experience
that you want to share,
or something you've found,
or something that you just want to talk about,
then please post below.
Preferably keep it about
what we discussed in this episode
to avoid spoilers for other people.
But generally, I think,
you guys expect spoilers at this point.
So yeah, let me know.
I'll catch you guys next time!
So there are some new mechanics in Dark Souls 2,
that I feel like you guys need to know about.
These are things
that aren't explained in-game,
and whether you're new
to the Souls Series or not...